okay so you're a rail shop you're all in
the cloud um you're using a lot of
different Amazon
Services um and you mentioned uh that
you had a lot of different sort of data
components or data services that you're
using um tell us like for for for those
of our audience who don't know um tell
us a little bit about the differences
between the AWS data
options right so um we use we we use a
lot of our data we use just a regular
SQL type of store because it's quick to
access we can query across it things
like that so you know we have we have a
concept of a retailer with a campaign
and the offers that they're trying to
give out to their customers we use my
SQL or the SQL data store to store all
that kind of information um but then we
also have a really large number of user
objects so not not only do we have to
deal with scaling we'll only have a
certain number of clients that are
giving our offers a fairly small but the
number of consumers that are redeeming
these offers is magnitude larger
um so we have a lot more objects in that
space and it needs to be Global a global
data store so we we want to have just
one database of users um across the
whole world um rather than partitioning
out we can partition out some of our
Enterprise clients um onto different
servers or things like that so for our
user store we're actually using simple
DB um to store some of the fast user
data and then we're also using offline
storage for because we're also so we
part of our process is the user Facebook
connects with us and gives us their data
such as likes that we can use to predict
what other the things offers they would
be interested in from us um and we're
also just trying to understand the
shopping habits of these users according
to their social data um so that data is
actually quite large um we could use a
blob store and SQL to to store it but it
makes more sense to just we don't need
it to be served up we it's just purely
for offline processing so we actually
write it out to S3 to disk okay can you
give me a quick use case on on both
sides of that fence like what what's an
example of a type of data that you're
using real time and what's an example of
a type of data that you're interested in
more batch mode um in real time we maybe
just want to know how many friends you
have and how many likes you have in
aggregate so i' just store an integer to
say how many friends and how many likes
you have um offline mode a lot of our
retailers are interested in what are the
top likes of our users um so that's we
have to actually go in and store
individual users and even to the
granularity of what's the most popular
in the retail category versus the music
category okay okay interesting